this video is about how to write clean
code in your formatting and comments
first formatting formatting is
subjective the main point is not to
argue over formatting just choose a
certain type of formatting between you
and your team and just go with it it's
important to be consistent I'm just
going to go over a few things about
formatting one is that you should use
consistent capitalization so here's an
example of the bad way you can see
there's two constants here so you could
choose either way as long as you're
consistent but we're gonna change this
to days okay
and down here we have two arrays and we
have this song's array in the artist
array we're just going to make this not
capitalized so I'll be consistent now we
have two functions this one's camelcase
this one's not so let's change this so
it's consistent and then we have two
classes just make sure they're
consistent if this is lowercase this
should be lowercase next up is function
callers and colleagues should be close
together ideally the color should be
right above the colleague we tend to
read code from top to bottom so it
should make sense just reading down how
the code supposed to go together so
let's look at this bad example we have a
bunch of functions and we're gonna
change the order here you can see that
this perf review function calls three
other functions so we're gonna just cut
that out and put that first and the
first function it calls is get peer
reviews so let's put that one right
after the perfect u and this calls
lookup Peter so put that one at sits
already next and now the next one that
this perfect views function calls us get
manager reviews so we'll put that next
and this is going to call lookup manager
so that's next and now this calls get
self review which we will put last here
so now we've reordered the functions in
this so it makes more sense it kind of
reads in order now now we're going to
move on to comments only comment things
that have business logic complexity
comments are an apology not a
requirement good code comments itself so
let's look at a piece of code here we
have this fun
ah [ __ ] and then look at the first
comment the hash well we can tell it's
the hash that's what the name of the
variable is let's take down one out and
then we have length of string well we
can see just by reading the strength of
code that this is the length of the
string so I don't need that comment
and this says loop through every
character and data yeah I think most
people know that four means it's a loop
so we can take that one out
get character code well it says right
here to care code yet so see a lot of
comments are unnecessary make the hash
well we're saying hash equals something
so we must be making the hash this is
only comment we're gonna keep convert to
32-bit integer because this may be a
little less obvious to some people what
it means so you can still keep some
comments just not nothing that's pretty
easy to figure out just by looking at
the code next thing is don't leave
commented out code in your code base
that's why we have version control so if
you have this function do stuff and then
you had all these other functions and
you're not using him anymore so you
counted them out just get rid of them
because you can always go back using
your version control system to previous
versions and you don't need to keep that
in your code next up is don't have
journal comments this is another thing
that you should use your version control
for use git log to get the history of
your code so you don't need to have the
history right in your code so we're just
going to delete all these and then the
last one is avoid positional markers so
this right here these are these are
markers just to so you can see where in
your code you are pretty easily but they
just add noise you should let the
functions and variable names and just
how you format the code give your the
structure to your code so you don't need
these well thanks for watching this has
been the last video in my clean code
series all these videos were based on
Ryan McDermott's great article on the
topic you can check the link in the
description to see the original article
my name is beau Carnes don't forget to
subscribe and remember use your code for
good